if you are serious about growing your
YouTube channel you're going to love
this video I have two special guests on
sharing what they wish they knew back
when they started their YouTube channels
we're going to be going through 10
specific strategies with about 25
different tactics and so this is a power
pack session this was recorded recently
and we're going to be diving into this
so get ready to take notes smash like if
you are fighting this is a special
interview with to get into this session
welcome to this special interview with
Matt DeMayo and Timmy danzo that are
going to be breaking now what we wish we
knew when starting YouTube we have 10
concrete strategies for you probably 25
tactics and we're gonna get straight
into it and I want to First welcome uh
Matt demaio to the Show Now Matt
um is he teaches you how to learn and he
is
um he produces how to focus how to learn
how to study he helps people raise their
gpas he has over a hundred and fifty
four thousand subscribers on YouTube and
so I want to Welcome Matt to the show
today and Matt thanks so much for being
here can you introduce yourself tell us
a little bit about your story and we're
going to check out your channel why
you're telling us wonderful well first
of all Sean I am both pleased and
honored to have an opportunity to be
presenting with you while I'm a a huge
fan of what what you guys are doing at
VRA the value that I'm getting is is
really remarkable you know I'm
self-taught as a YouTuber I just
celebrated my 70th birthday
and I got into this whole YouTube thing
only a couple of years ago because I
unexpectedly had a video uh that I had
that one right there uh I had that video
suddenly take off after it was on
YouTube about two years it started to
get some traction and then four years
later it actually started having a lot
of growth very quickly I mentioned it to
a friend of mine that uh that all of a
sudden I had this Little Orphan video
take off and he asked me if I was
monetized at that point I really didn't
know what he was talking about and
um so I began to to to learn about what
what the story was that one little video
got me enough subscribers and enough
watch time that I was instantly
qualified for the YouTube partners
program
um and so I I began to throw myself into
it but I was completely self-taught and
uh so I've I've struggled a good bit but
coming across your training has been
really enlightening to me
um and it's just been a tremendous help
so yeah with 156 000 and change
subscribers over 8 million views on my
videos I am a man on a mission to make a
positive lasting difference in the lives
of students of all ages around the world
because I have students that are you
know continuing learning adults all the
way down to you know the majority of my
audience are college kids and uh so that
gives you a little bit of insight as to
where I'm at and and what I'm doing
man I love it Matt and so grateful
you're here and a VRA member and love
how you're helping people learn
everything faster and easier
um and excited to get into some of your
tips but we also have with us today
Tammy danzo and temmie is an incredible
artist
um she was a mechanical engineer turned
full-time artist who now creates art
videos on YouTube she has a YouTube
short out on her personal Channel and on
her Instagram that's so inspiring of all
the Milestones that hit in like a year
of her life uh and one of those things
becoming a full-time artist and growing
to 350 000 subscribers on YouTube but in
just the last month you had 11 million
views and 30 000 new subscribers in just
the last month so we're excited to learn
from you but Tammy can you break down a
little bit of your story
um for the VRA fam and the challenge
crew yes definitely and first I'd just
like to say thank you so much for having
me I'm also massively honored to be here
two years ago I was part of the seven
day challenge and I've still got my
notebook and my color-coded notes from
then and it was incredible then and so
I'm psyched for you guys and make sure
you're taking your notes you're
definitely going to get so much value
from it but for me and on my channel
um I started YouTube around 10 years ago
however I wasn't it was very sporadic
very random videos as we can see it was
mostly even just pictures and then I
came back around two years ago with a
goal of just uploading Drawing Tutorials
ever so often I was also doing bullet
Journal videos at the time yeah this is
my first this is my first video back
where I was just trying to get back into
the YouTube thing or trying to get into
the YouTube thing and kind of similar to
Matt I really didn't really know what I
was doing I was just kind of doing
drawings and just uploading what I
thought speed drawings and my content
changed a lot I went into more bullet
journal and more planning videos and
then I also proceeded to do Drawing
Tutorials where I was teaching people
and just showing them my entire my
entire drawing process from start to
finish
um and that's basically the Journey of
my YouTube channel at the moment I do
more challenge Style videos so I have
the learning side where people want to
improve their own art and I try to teach
them and now I do one color challenges
three color challenges and just trying
to produce art and I'm so incredibly
honored to be able to do arts now full
time it's just an amazing privilege and
I'm so grateful to God
um but yeah that's essentially my
YouTube channel I'm now a full-time
artist
man your story is so inspiring and we're
going to get straight into these tips
and lessons and we'll just kind of be
going back and forth but the first tip
today is you gotta start and be
consistent and one of the things you
would mention as we were kind of hearing
about some of your tips uh preparing for
this uh timi was was the power of
consistency and so expand on that a
little bit of what you've noticed from
being consistent on YouTube
yes I think starting is the hardest bit
but realistically being consistent is
almost a few that will keep you going
and I think Sean uses the analogy of a
snowball and honestly you can't get gain
momentum if you're not consistent and
consistency is what brings that but
consistency is so important because your
audience get gets used to expecting you
at a certain point but it also makes you
focus and it keeps you on track to just
continue to create the content it's so
important it can't be understated for me
on my channel when I came back two and a
half years ago that's when I decided
every single week I was doing one video
every single week without fail I'm not
saying you should do it also we all have
our different plans and we have our
different lives I think just choose
something that works for you and just
stick to it
that I love that and Matt I'm curious
for you you've uploaded 65 videos on
your channel what have you noticed about
just being consistent on YouTube over
the years
well I uh I've got to confess that I did
not start out being very consistent at
all
um and that I guess was a real issue for
my viewers but the more I began to put
videos up and I began to get feedback in
the comment section from viewers all
over the world and I suddenly realized
that I'm I'm making a difference far
from what I expected uh you know I
thought I'd have some impact but the
type of testimonials and comments that
people write to me are so over the top
about the lives that are that I'm
touching with this
um you know I I don't want to sound too
corny but you know Sean you came from
the church background but like I'm like
from The Blues Brothers movie I'm I'm on
a mission from God
and I found out that as a result of
consistently posting
um my audience is now I've been able to
build a real relationship with them when
they show up on my on my premiers I know
them by their usernames and I interact
with them and so I'm building
relationships with people who have names
that cannot be spelled with my alphabet
so amazing and that brings us to point
number two which is create a Content
plan and yeah if you fail to plan you
plan to fail and so uh in just a second
Matt I want to hear a little bit about
how you come up with content and how you
plan your content uh but Timmy you uh
you were really serious or you you
really were passionate about this point
what is uh your tips on this one
yes I think we can say consistency be
consistent from now tone actually about
how do you actually go about it I think
a plan is really what will help you so I
had a Content calendar so I said I
wanted to upload one video every single
week and I had 52 rows down my page
every single Sunday which was my upload
days and video ideas one thing you you
can never run out of video ideas you
need to have a running list of ideas
that you can easily swap in I think it's
so important to have a plan because if
you plan if you fail to plan you plan to
fail but ultimately as well I think when
you have a plan you you can easily go
into it and you never have to be stuck
basically but with my content plan what
helped me so much was having that list
like I said and also at different times
of the year you want to know when you
can drop different nuggets so for
example with my bullet Journal content
all the creators did plan with me videos
let's say the third week of them the
previous month and for me I wanted to
get ahead of it I wanted to rank my
videos so I actually uploaded mine the
second week of the month so my videos
came up and people's search before and
because I was alert and I knew the
timing I could easily Implement that and
I got more views that way so you can
apply this to your own content as well
if it's got to do with Black Friday
sales if it's something to do with
Christmas back to school just make sure
you create a plan and then you can
actually execute on it
I love that yeah one of the things we
talk about at think a lot is the word
foresight and without a plan and looking
ahead then sometimes holidays can come
up on you by surprise but you start the
further you look ahead you go okay like
you said Black Friday okay am I gonna do
something around Thanksgiving is there a
holiday is there something relevant you
know Matt is thinking back to school
right you could be thinking about winner
college students going back to when are
they really when are they crabbing for
tests and these different things but if
we if it's too late when that is
actually happening and a lot of times
you know it's the pre-planning that can
help us that by looking ahead on our
content calendars and I'm curious Matt
you know when it comes to your plan you
have a particular type of content and
you have so many different good video
ideas you know how is it that you come
up with your video ideas and plan them
out ahead of time well there's actually
a couple of things that I do and you
really um you uh kind of got into my
shoes there for just a quick moment I do
plan my my the release of different
content around what I think that the
majority of my students are going
through at that moment so I've really
taken the time to look at my analytics
and see who my audience is and see the
type of things that they're doing and so
when I know that college students are
taking final exams I'm gonna I publish
more things that have to do with exams
in when when it's a normal school
semester and things of that nature I
will I'll deviate a little bit so one of
my recent videos was on building
self-discipline and how you can program
your mind to create more self-discipline
not a school specific subject because so
many of my people have written comments
about gee I can't even get motivated I
can't I can't get myself to sit down and
do what needs to be done so I'm
responsive to their our needs but I look
at their schedule and what their
calendar looks like and I plan my
content around what I think will be most
useful for the majority of my audience
I love it and that brings us to tip
number three which is learn how the
algorithm works and that is everything
of course watching this even if we've
been doing this for a while even if
we're already a VRA member there's
something that we constantly are
learning about constantly trying to
understand and so Matt you know the
algorithm determines who your videos are
served up to what have you learned about
the YouTube algorithm strategically
you know that that has been a a
problematic issue for me and uh I'm glad
that you you brought that up what I
noticed was that
um regardless of what I do I'm I'm
discovering that it seems to me that
students from a variety of different
countries other than what I what I was
expecting
were consuming my videos at a much
higher rate so so the United States I'm
in Tampa Florida and so the United
States is only my number two Market
the the place where my videos are most
viewed is India of all and it's almost
twice the amount of people in India
viewing my videos as in the United
States in my top five I've also got the
Ukraine and Russia I I had no idea and
that's also affecting my YouTube
partnership ad Revenue because I don't
generate as much RPM or CPM as somebody
that has uh like for example a Golf
Channel where the the the the the viewer
is uh you know upper income person with
a lot of disposable money
um I have college students in foreign
lands so it I'm paying a lot more
attention right now
to how to create content that's going to
get viewed in Australia and England in
the United States and Canada
um and so it's been a struggle for me to
to figure those things out
I like I think there's a couple insights
there for me one when you start
sometimes you don't know what's going to
happen or who who's all going to be
interested in your content but two also
thinking about
who will find this content interesting
or what content do I need to create next
that would be the right content for if
you will my ideal audience and actually
I don't want to get too ahead of
ourselves because I want to go back into
CPM and RPM and all that kind of stuff a
little bit later and get geeky on some
monetization stuff but tell me
um I want to actually ask you a little
bit about your experience with the
algorithm and your tips but one thing I
also notice on your channel which is a
2022 strategy for sure and that is this
that some of your biggest few not some
of your top
8 12 14 videos are actually YouTube
shorts with your top video being a
YouTube short from two months ago with
14 million views getting 625 views an
hour so the algorithm is clearly pushing
out shorts on your channel 11 million
views in the last 30 days pretty crazy a
lot of new subscribers what are some of
the things you're noticing about the
YouTube algorithm right now and how
you've understanding I understood how it
works
yeah so I'll definitely say the YouTube
algorithm for normal videos it still
pushes that content out but like Sean
just said it's his pushing shorts like
crazy so I would encourage everybody to
jump on shorts it doesn't have to be
separate like you don't have to think of
it as a different
um social media website I think you can
just think of you can just add it to
your content so there was a time where I
really wanted to grow and grow with
shorts and so I was doing one shorts
every single Sunday alongside my regular
videos do whatever works for you like I
said come up with a plan for yourself
but for me and shorts I was already
familiar with short film content because
I was familiar with Tick Tock and I was
doing a lot of that content and it has a
different style to it I know people
struggle with how to best put their
content into short form I think the
first thing to do is to consume short
form content it's very different to long
form and there's no point you trying to
squeeze something that doesn't want to
be squeezed in basically it's mostly I
would say entertainment and just quick
easy bite-sized content for me on my art
Channel but it has been amazing it has
10x my growth it has grown my channel so
much I think I hit 100K in December and
now I'm at 350k and we're in April and
that's mostly down to short so I would
encourage everybody to
um yeah have a go at YouTube shorts and
you know the biggest most viewed video
on think media now too with 7.5 million
views or something is a YouTube short
and so
um shorts are definitely something that
the algorithm is favoring because they
want to compete with Tick Tock and reels
and short form content YouTube wants to
be in that game and so um that's
definitely something to consider now
number four is improve your video
quality of course when you think about
starting you gotta just punch fear in
the face just use whatever you have it's
encouraging to see some of Matt's early
accidentalies like I uploaded a video
and this video did well and you know
even Tammy's like you know some of my
early stuff was just a picture or
whatever but as time goes on we really
want to level up our our video quality
and what's interesting is you mentioned
that audio is actually more important
than video what have you learned about
that yes I 100 say someone is more
likely to stay with a bad quality or not
4K video if the audio is crisp compared
to a good video and bad audio so when
you want when you're ready to upgrade
your stuff and first I'll just like say
start with your phone I still use my
phone for a lot of my filming I do have
a camera as well but I still use my
phone for a lot of it um definitely
start with your phone the audio quality
on your phone is actually good enough as
well but when you're ready to upgrade
the first thing you should think about
is a microphone
um it's just going to up up your content
so much and then you can think about
upgrading your video and everything else
but another underrated tip is lighting
because you can have the best camera the
best phone in bad lighting is never
going to be good so sit in front of a
window or buy lights if you live in the
UK because the window is not really
doing anything for us and yeah
yep and you know of course I want to
encourage you uh we have our think media
channel which is free and Nolan and uh
Omar myself Heather we're over there
helping with audio helping you with uh
all kinds of video editing and all that
kind of stuff so you probably know that
by now but I also if you haven't entered
yet
um we are giving away a YouTube studio
so um you can go to win this tech.com uh
there's eight days left uh win this
tech.com and remember start with what
you have one of the things Tammy told me
was focus on creating the best videos
um but don't be a perfectionist just
work on improving one thing at a time
and that might be just getting a mic off
Amazon or getting a tripod and maybe
just improving where you film your
videos during when uh near the window or
whatever but you know if you go to win
this tech.com we are going to be giving
away a Sony zve E10 and a light kit and
a microphone and so highly recommend
entering over there
um and we're gonna keep it moving
because as I'm excited to geek out a
little bit on some little-known terms
and that is understand the ypp
that CPM and RPM what what did Sean just
say right and so understand the YouTube
Partner program understand CPM and
what's the difference between CPM and
RPM we're going to bring Matt back and
he touched on this a little bit earlier
but Matt what have you learned you
mentioned you know understanding that it
affected your cpms and RPMs different
viewers and so explain what you've
learned about the partner program and
what your experience has been here
well you know this is one of the things
that I that I really wish that I knew a
lot more about because it's been a
little bit frustrating
um the um
the
the
way I generate Revenue through the
through the partner program I didn't
realize
um especially getting started and I'm
only beginning to understand it better
now that where my beauty videos are
viewed the country that they're viewed
in and the audience that they're that
they're being displayed to is going to
significantly impact the amount of money
that I generate and so I'm I'm looking
for ways to figure out how to do it
better and it was one of those things
that I put on my list of things that I
wish I knew because quite frankly Sean I
wish I knew it better even right now uh
I'm because I'm focused on it because
I'm I'm aware that this is an issue I am
really focusing my content uh in a way
that helps me drive my audience to you
know higher paid higher paid uh RPM but
um
I don't I don't really have a good
feedback other than what I've just said
yeah absolutely well this that's also
what I'm here for and so I I think I uh
everyone would benefit a little bit from
this conversation so the ypp is the
YouTube Partner program once you hit a
thousand subscribers and 4 000 hours of
watch time minutes within the last 12
months rolling you're allowed to apply
and once you get approved for
monetization then you can start earning
monies earning money from views on your
videos but only if ads play
so just because you get a million views
doesn't mean that an ad played on every
single one of those videos even if you
turn ads on YouTube does decide whether
or not they want to play an ad and
people can use ad blockers and so what
ends up happening is again you're only
going to get paid if people actually see
an ad it's how many monetizable views
you have and then CPM stands for cost
per Milli we're going to get kind of
geeky and these are some pretty cool
numbers and so no need to compare but we
could break down what we can learn here
you know in the last uh year of think
media our CPM was twenty dollars and
that's per a thousand views of a actual
ad playback we earn 20.74 cents now
that's pretty high because a lot of
times uh it's about two to five dollars
is the average CPM on YouTube if you
have a lot of international viewers or a
lot of young viewers it can be even
lower than that but this number is not
how much you make that's how much
YouTube charges advertisers the CPM now
the RPM is actually how much you make
it's the revenue per a thousand views
and then YouTube's kind of tricky with
this one because they they combine your
Super Chat and any kind of memberships
and things in here and luckily
for our sake for accuracy we don't have
Channel memberships we don't do a ton of
live streams on think Media or anything
so it doesn't get too convoluted with
super chats and so here's what we're
discovering right at least in our case
we make less than 50 percent we make
about nine dollars
YouTube makes 11. we make nine when it
comes to our RPM
um and this was over 2021 for our
Channel and a couple tips there as Matt
mentioned you know we're talking about
software and cameras so a lot more
premium tech companies and whatnot want
to advertise on our Channel
our viewers are serious in a lot of
cases because it's educational we're not
really in entertainment although we hope
to be edutainment
our content is is tutorial based
education based and it it attracts
people like you that are serious
creators and a large viewership in the
US as well as internationally so those
types of things can drive up your
channel if you if you have a lot of
international viewers watching live
streams of of cats you know just kind of
compilations of cat videos you might get
a lot of views but your CPM could be a
lot lower and I know it's kind of a
shocking number but that's why in a
year's time we generated almost four
hundred thousand dollars on think media
because of high CPM because of the views
we're getting and also the quality of
views we're getting and so uh definitely
something to uh to know a little about
and I'm curious with Tammy uh as far as
I don't want to jump ahead too much uh
but as far as ad revenue and Matt's
going to be sharing later too he's got a
course and some books and some other
things happening
um but what percent of of your overall
business being able to do this full-time
do you rely on your ad Revenue
so my ad revenue is a pretty high
percent at the moment and that's because
I've got other things in the works but
they're not quite there yet however my
ad revenue is nowhere near think media's
I get the two to five dollars that you
were mentioning
um because as an art Channel there's
just advertising not really trying to do
that but um yeah and I'm curious what's
happened with the shorts fund that's one
other thing we should touch on YouTube
shorts minutes watch do not count
towards monetization and
you shorts can be watched on desktop so
you can actually earn some traditional
ad Revenue through them but they
actually pay you separately through
What's called the shorts fund I know for
us we we had a 7.5 million viewed short
and we made around a hundred dollars
from it whereas if we get 7.5 million
views on think media we make
twenty five thousand dollars based on
those on our full length content so it's
pretty crazy so are you been getting uh
some shorts fund Revenue separately yes
I have and I think on average I make
like a thousand dollars from YouTube
shorts for I don't know how many views I
do from shorts
um it's definitely not comparable and
from traditional AdSense those shorts
videos get like a one penny
um each but yeah there is a chunk from
the shorts fund as well we're deep
that's some good kind of insights and
some good thinking and you know
contextually I would say too it sort of
speaks to oh I shouldn't do shorts
because it doesn't pay as well in
AdSense well no shorts or reach you know
it's it's can be viewership it also
depends on your Niche but it's so
encouraging to hear a thousand dollars
from YouTube shorts view views and
growth and then there's also something
to be said if you're really thinking
about and this is what we talk about a
Niche Finder right really thinking about
your proficiency uh also your passions
and then also what's the most profitable
the new the niche you select
can influence the ad revenue or not only
can Will influence how much ad Revenue
you get how much CPM RPM and all those
kinds of things but we're going to keep
it moving and uh if you've been enjoying
this smash the hearts and the like
button in here in the Facebook groups
because uh if you're missing this then
you're missing out I'll tell you what
right VRA and challenge this is pretty
good stuff number six though is we're
talking about optimize your thumbnails
titles and your description uh we're
going to start with timi and uh you
really know that thumbnails and titles
are a big deal what have you learned
about these
so much I'll say I don't know about you
guys but when I go on the YouTube
homepage I'm clicking all of the ones
that catch my attention and that's
exactly what your thumbnail also needs
to do and you're really in competition
against anyone else that person might be
interested in so it's so important I
think for me personally it really needs
to evoke curiosity someone needs to know
what they're getting so you don't want a
repetition from your title to your
thumbnail but you need it to complement
each other really well and yeah just
what would you actually click on if you
think about it and something I've tried
implementing recently are trying to do
three main elements so that it's not too
crowded I'd do maybe a face maybe an
object if it's a pen to an iPad and then
a bit of text so you don't want it to be
too crowded as well which is something I
definitely struggle with but you want to
have enough information so someone is
willing to click on it but then actually
get them to click and if you think about
it you might have the best video of all
time it could be a 10 out of 10 video
you've improved everything you've put
all your learnings into it but if nobody
clicks on it nobody's gonna know that
it's their best video so just focus on
actually getting people to click on your
videos by really creating eye-catching
thumbnails and titles as well
I love it and Matt tell us a little bit
you talk about you know video
descriptions and thinking about keywords
TAPS in a little bit of video record
Academy what have you kind of learned in
that area
well first of all the um the idea of
being able to write a description that
is friendly to the YouTube algorithm has
been really helpful and I keep getting a
little better with each video that I've
been doing on my most recent video about
the three things that top students do
differently
um I I'm seeing a a big change in the
trajectory of how fast that video caught
on because I I really studied what some
of my competitors are doing in in the
same Niche that I'm in uh to take a look
and see what are the descriptions
um I subscribe to vid IQ and also the
tubebuddy and so I use both of them to
help me come up with the keywords and I
I'm I've gotten a lot better at putting
these keywords into the sentence
description in my underneath my videos
um
also going back to thumbnails for a
moment I've been making my thumbnails a
lot simpler big text with a value
proposition right up front
um and uh a lot of times I'll repeat
well most of my title in the in the
thumbnail itself because I know that
sometimes people just don't like to read
the little text underneath the video and
it's you know if I can Bonk them on the
head a little bit and go hey this is
what the video is about because people
have so much choice and you've only got
a moment to catch their attention
um I'm doing everything that I can to
really focus them in on here's what
you're going to get here's how you
benefit
from this video
man I love it some really good tips
there and one of the things uh you know
so you have current information as well
uh is is description still a really good
way to communicate with uh the Youtube
algorithm particularly the first
sentence tags carry a lot less weight
these days uh but your title carries a
ton of weight and what I love is I agree
your thumbnails are very clear I love
how short this title is how clear this
title is and one of the most powerful
things uh Matt that I see also doing
here is is Chapters and so you know
chapters especially in a video where
there is teaching or education I love we
can get to proof of the experiment and
we can navigate the video we've learned
that chapters can be and are indexed
even on Google Search and parts of our
videos find their way to Google search
because of using chapters and you know
to do that you can just add time codes
and you start off with zero zero colon
zero zero and once you just type these
in here with something next to them it
turns into the chapters on the video and
highly recommended they're called time
codes or time stamps and they turn into
chapters and YouTube actually allows you
to um you can see it right here if you
click here YouTube breaks it up into a
whole chapter section where you can
organize your video and um not only have
we taught about that in VRA extensively
but in in uh dra Masters and some of the
updates we're continuing to add I'll be
ready because we've learned a ton about
chapters lately as well all right this
is an exciting topic that we're getting
into next but we've talked about start
and be consistent two create a Content
Plan Three learn how the algorithm works
for improve the video quality five
understand the YouTube Partner program
CPM and RPM six optimize your thumbnails
titles and description but number seven
we're we're talking about creating
multiple streams of income and so um man
you need money for the mission how do
you fund this thing and what's so cool
is whether it's uh temi or Matt they
have different business models yesterday
if uh we we learned from Sean Chandler
and from Christina they have different
business models and so we're going to
start with Matt though and uh tell us a
little bit about your income streams
sponsors uh anything that you're doing
when it comes to creating multiple
streams of income
well first of all
um one of the things that I wanted to do
was to be able to collect data on my
audience so in the description
underneath the video in one of the the
little sections I offer a free report
about how to Triple your memory power
without mnemonics or Association or
memory tricks and so they can then opt
in
to get information and now I've got them
on a on an email campaign I've got them
on an email list so that I can
communicate with them directly
um another thing that I did is I I
started making courses available now
I've got one course that's up and
running right now I keep the the tuition
extremely low because I know my audience
and it's on how to have an incredible
memory
um I've also got inexpensive books there
you go that's the page
I've got some books on Amazon that I
like to direct people to
and so
um I recently started offering merch on
my channel I'm still learning about how
to do that a little bit better so um
I've got I've got my own line of coffee
mugs and and some T-shirts and things of
that nature that's going to take a
little while for me to understand that
better to take off
but I've got a lot of I've got a lot of
other stuff planned but one of the
things that I'm going to be doing is
really with my live streams I'm hoping
to be able to attract people who just
because they dig what I'm doing want to
donate a little bit of money I've spoken
to other you know professional YouTubers
that say that sometimes the audience can
be very generous and I like that idea
man so many inspiring ideas and kind of
speaks to that that
um there's so many different paths you
can create to prosperity in the crater
economy it's really about picking out
what works for you maybe things you're
passionate about
um but I want to hear from temi and now
uh you've grown so much you got 350
000 subscribers but we can get into some
of the um ways you're monetizing the
most and some of the things you did
early on but you had a warning you
actually said don't worry about
sponsorships early on because some
Brands want to prey on small creators
and it's not worth the hassle can you
expand on that a little bit
yes I think I can speak for any small
Creator when you get that one email like
a brand is actually looking out for you
it's amazing to receive that email but a
lot of Brands especially early on they
want to give you they want to ask so
much from you and I don't think it's
worth it I think it's much more
beneficial to use that time to actually
build your audience build your community
and build people that know like and
trust you on the other hand I do think
you can do other monetization
opportunities so for example affiliate
marketing that's something I started
very very early on by the way I'm not
saying don't do sponsorships early on
I'm just saying those brands that are
telling you buy the product and then
give you your firstborn child and all of
that don't do that but um stuff like
affiliate marketing works so so well
it's even when you're smaller and I
think especially if you're in a niche so
for example when I was doing bullet
Journal content every single plan with
me I was using my planners so guess what
I would link my planners and I was
getting a good 500 to a thousand dollars
every month with three four thousand
subscribers and yeah it's it's almost
understated all the different avenue
streams you can have but don't fall into
the Trap of just taking any sponsorship
because it came up yeah that's a really
good point and and what you'll notice to
spot these sometimes even on Instagram
you'll get somebody that'll say hey like
we want to sponsor your channel we want
to feature you and then they'll say okay
so all you got to do is first buy the
sunglasses or buy the stuff
um and you might get emails we want to
put you in our Network we want to uh we
want to do and and I agree you kind of
want to avoid that stuff it could be
tempting it could be a distraction focus
on building your influence focus on
building momentum and take the power
back in your hands yes you should
definitely maybe take the right
sponsorships but one of the other things
you're doing to me is patreon speak a
little bit about that and
um expound on what you've learned here
yes so I recently started my patreon by
recently I mean last week literally 1st
of April is when I opened it but for me
it's just a place to have exclusive
content for your super fans that want to
connect with you even deeper so some of
the rewards like you can see on screen
Early Access to videos and up to monthly
live streams and it's just a chance for
me to give people a little bit extra on
YouTube you know you want to make the
video educational but also entertaining
and this is just a place to go deeper
see the people that want the extra
tutorials or the extra long um Drawing
Tutorials they can get access to that so
that's what I use patreon for I love it
well that was number seven create
multiple streams of income number eight
is tap into the power of YouTube live
and we'll go back to Tammy in just a
second and look at one of her recent
live streams but Matt this is something
that you're doing I'm curious
um if you're just streaming live on
YouTube you touched on it earlier about
building that out do you multi-stream it
all do you keep it on YouTube and what
have you learned about going live
well
um I haven't done as I haven't done very
many lives the few that I've done the
interaction with my audience has been
really quite rewarding
um my uh well I'm I'm doing YouTube on a
very part-time basis because even though
I'm a much older guy I still have
clients that I I write content for them
and so uh my schedule doesn't always
allow me to be as active on YouTube as I
might like
but doing live streams has been for me
one of the most rewarding experiences
because I'm able to interact immediately
and most of my videos are scripted and
I'm using a teleprompter but when I am
you know free-flowing with my audience
that's just a hoot um for many years I
was a professional speaker so I was on
stage uh you know traveling around North
America doing shows doing presentations
and that is the closest I've come to
having that feeling back again of being
able to interact with my audience live
so I'm planning on doing that a whole
lot more I've struggled a little bit
with the scheduling issues I I'm not
sure what the what the the story is but
um it's something that I definitely need
to learn better and while you have me
here today in the position of a of a
teacher or really I'm an eternal student
you know that's that's why I'm here
because I I've learned a long time ago
that the the best way to learn is to
teach but also I've never stepped out of
the student role myself so I'm always
looking to pick up every little nugget I
can
man I love that I I'm right there with
you Matt and I love I agree YouTube live
uh can give you such a cool interactive
opportunity with your community
um and you know what we'd also recommend
in in light of ease of scheduling one of
our favorite tools is exactly what we're
using right here now of course we can uh
we'll put our affiliate link you know if
you haven't signed up for stream yard
but we really believe in it that much
like
um it makes it so easy to right now
we're going live in our VRA group for
the VRA show this month we have our
challenge going on so we're going live
there yesterday we went live in those
two groups and on our think media
podcast Channel but it's so cool because
scheduling is very easy you can upload
your title ahead of time your
description content ahead of time your
thumbnail ahead of time and yes for sure
there's a learning curve but I have
never I've used some very complex live
streaming tools and you might be kind of
intimidated by live streaming I'm sure
if you're watching this oh like there's
so much I think about and you don't want
to be thinking about the technology and
the tools you want to be able to focus
as much as you can and even think about
this like I'm managing the show by
myself I'm able to bring temmy on share
my screen put the banners up I've been
doing this for a while so I I've
developed the the but streamer makes it
easy I'm able to just send the back end
here you know click on the banners and
throw up the banner about tap into the
power of YouTube live which actually
really brings me to I want to hear from
temi here about what you've learned and
I've got one of your live streams up I'm
curious you know what kind of software
are you using and what's kind of neat
here is it looks like
um you're you're doing kind of like a
draw with me live which is kind of cool
breakdown what you've learned here and
uh what you like or some tips about
YouTube live
yeah I mean firstly this is very
embarrassing to have on screen because
this is my first live stream and it was
a mess but I will second that stream
yard 10 out of 10 because if you look at
the YouTube backstream back yeah for
lives it's it's so complicated it's
scary yeah it's very scary but God made
it so much easier and I think personally
with lives just to Echo some of what
Matt was saying the connection with your
audience so that was a draw with me I
was just you know doing a bit of drawing
and just even being able to communicate
communicate with them live it's such an
underrated thing because you think oh
yeah reply to comments all the time but
it's so different and I mean for your
favorite creators as well how do you
feel when they call your name out I feel
like it's just an amazing amazing
feeling so oh yeah this is my second
life slightly better still on a stream
yard but this was me doing Diamond
painting and it was just amazing to
answer questions have things up on the
screen just incredible
man so cool and so if this doesn't sound
right for you you're not ready yet then
you don't got to do it yet but know that
there's some cool things in your road
map of building your creator career and
I like what Matt said too
um there's if you want to use a
teleprompter use one one of my favorites
is the parrot teleprompter because you
can actually just put your phone on
there get a little teleprompter app on
your phone put your phone up in front of
your camera
um you may need two phones if you're
using your phone I got two phones okay
uh and uh that's an option for you or
you know the power of editing is it
makes anybody you think looks really
great right like oh man they're such
good communicator they're probably not
as good as you think because they're
cutting out the ums they're able to kind
of reshoot different parts of their
content so the key is to just take
Massive Action if you feel confident to
go live go live if you want to um you
know experiment with editing experiment
with editing do a little bit of
everything because it'll help you get
better and experiment with more things
which brings us to tip number nine which
is keep learning growing and studying
now Matt already kind of mentioned on
this we agree lifelong leaders are
lifelong learners
right we continue to learn we continue
to level up I want to talk to Matt a
little bit more about this in a second
but there's interesting thing you said
to me about also learning from other
creators and not just creators in your
Niche what have you discovered with that
yeah so I think for most people that
watch YouTube you don't just watch a
particular Niche and even though you
might create content in a particular
Niche I feel like you can get tips from
all over so I watch random like Mr Beast
videos and I can get information about
the editing or the storytelling I think
there's so much to be learned just from
consuming YouTube so I think it's
important to look obviously all over
your niche as well look at the top
creators but just look at creators all
around the board who do you enjoy
watching why do you enjoy watching them
what keeps you staying till the end of
their video it's things that you
probably little nuggets that you can
then Implement into your videos
yep absolutely brilliant and then Matt
what would you say when it comes to uh
continuing your education and maybe what
are some things you've learned you're a
communicator you're a speaker you've
sharpened your skills not just as it
pertains directly to things like YouTube
and so what how do you feel about
investing in your learning and how
you've just leveled up in business and
all these areas
you know that this is this is absolutely
my favorite uh topic here you know is
you know it's the ability to continually
stay sharp one of the things that I I
always do is I make sure that on every
single video that I I use a a new
editing trick I use a new tactic that
I've recently learned
um I I've I watch other people's YouTube
videos with a much different eye than I
used to because when I was just
consuming content and not creating it I
didn't notice all of the the ways they
edit or communicate or how they use
b-roll and now when I watch other people
regardless of what Niche they're in I
like a lot of the music channels and uh
well I I notice how they communicate to
Their audience how they do their editing
where they use their b-roll and so my
I'm much more um I have more of an x-ray
vision when I'm when I'm watching other
people's YouTube channels and then I uh
instead of just sitting back and looking
at it I try and figure out a way that I
can make some of those ideas my own in
my very next video and so far video
after video I've always come up with new
tactics and new techniques
that uh that help improve my viewers
experience
I love it I love it and we're going to
get to number 10 in just a second
um but I do want to remind you if you're
watching this in our challenge group
again if you are ready to take your
learning to the next level you know uh
if anyone here is happens to be in the
challenge group from VRA you know let us
know your experience you know in the in
the challenge we're doing seven sessions
it's all for free
um but trust me I mean join us inside of
the video record Academy because that's
really where you could take your
learning to the next level but before we
get into Point number 10 uh I just want
to kind of ask you uh temi specifically
um you joined during the challenge uh
what was helpful about VRA for you in
helping you reach the results you've got
on YouTube today
so it was amazing at the time I had
around 3 000 subscribers and I had
floating ideas in my mind and I was
trying to do everything and it just
helped me to really fine tune I remember
one thing in particular that really
stood out for me which was I think like
a title in workbook or something I don't
know if I've got that wrong but it just
changed the way I saw my titles and how
I wrote my titles which just then
leveled up one percent the next time and
honestly even the mindset behind it and
I think I really love the company as
well and I love how it started with the
mentor and you have Heather you know
hyping us up in the team just everything
about it just made this a family and a
community that I've really wanted to
join and then obviously the actual
YouTube knowledge and the experience you
know you've grown a channel to over a
million subscribers so much information
wealth of knowledge honestly the list is
endless to be honest I appreciate you
sharing that too and I'm curious Matt
just your experience again uh tackling
YouTube when did you join video record
Academy and how did you find it well you
know um I I try and subscribe to as many
different lists as I can and um it was
around Halloween of last year around the
end of October when I had to come across
one of your ads and I attended some of
the free seminars and then when you ran
your Black Friday special after
Thanksgiving I that's when I decided to
pull the trigger and join VRA because
prior to that I had already spent money
on personal coaching and I said spent
more for one afternoon of personal
coaching
than the entire VRA program cost me I I
spent 1250 which was good money well
spent I got a lot of value from some
coaches that I worked with uh gotten a
lot of value from it but then when I
joined VRA for hundreds of dollars less
than that and I've got all of these
Services plus a community plus a
Facebook uh group to belong to it has
just been it's been one of the best
things I've ever done
um because not only is there constant
education but there's also a community
of other people that you can contribute
a little bit about what you know you can
also see other people's perspectives on
it
um you can sit back and receive
tremendous education from authoritative
sources that know what they're talking
about so it's not it's not just colored
through one lens you're able to see it
uh you know with a variety of
perspectives and I want to wrap up with
talking about the idea the basics you
know if we were talking about baseball
you know there's four basics hit run
throw catch if you can hit run throw
catch really well and you never get you
know you never outgrow doing those four
basics
the better you're able to do it the more
of a pro you are
and so VRA has helped me realize that I
had jumped into the deep end of the pool
without really understanding the basics
at all you know I just was using my gut
instinct that having been a speaker and
a writer and an author and a trainer I I
know I could communicate I didn't really
understand all of the mechanics about
how involved and how how much finesse I
needed to use in in terms of building my
YouTube audience and so I'm really glad
I found you guys
man so grateful for you and and grateful
you're a part of our community and uh we
still have a number 10 uh 10th Point um
and let our guests go at the top of the
hour here thanks so much for being here
we got one more tip though for you and
it's it's not too late to start YouTube
now I want to hear from them in just a
second and uh obviously they've had a
lot of success and timi in just a short
amount of time and started a new channel
um but a couple reminders you know
um Forbes released this article that
said the crater economy is currently
valued at 20 billion with estimations
that it could be 104 billion by the end
of 2022. YouTube alone is expected to
generate 30 billion in Revenue by the
end of this year from self-made
entrepreneurs and remember that 30
billion just like I showed you with CPM
and RPM about half of that money goes
into the pockets of creators you know
the the whole Creator economy is valued
at about 20 million and so what does
that mean that's Matt making money also
off of is the books he's written and his
course and that's Timmy also as she's
building out her patreon and it's all
these different income streams but what
shocks me about this article is that
it's saying how much growth Forbes is
estimating in just the next nine months
5x growth whether you've been doing this
for a while or whether you're just
starting there's a real wave happening
right now right and of course Sean you'd
say that to Hype us up well maybe but if
this isn't based on my opinion this is
based on logic and real data because
this is the fastest growing type of
small business like Heather was talking
about surfing today with that analogy
it's a wave that's happening and it's
good to get positioned right now it's
good to double down right now there's
certain timing there's certain moments
where you want to take action to seize
an opportunity and we're really seeing
this with again what we're calling this
not not what we're calling this what
it's being called it's the Creator
economy
kind of a new class of self-made
entrepreneurs working from home working
on their own terms and so I'm I'm
curious about this first mat and then uh
Timmy your thoughts is what do you feel
like I mean as you're you've been doing
this for a while but you also have over
a hundred thousand subscribers when you
look ahead at the Horizon of what's
ahead what's kind of your perspective
what do you see ahead what gets you
excited you mentioned you have some
plans uh what is your thoughts when you
think about it not being not too late to
jump into the game
well it is clearly not too late I think
that uh that uh you know we're just at
the uh for me personally I'm just at the
beginning of where my journey is look I
got started with this whole thing in my
late 60s and I just like I said I just
turned 70 and I'm looking forward to
what's going to happen in the years to
come
um you know this is not just a business
for me this is uh like I said at the
beginning this is a mission that I'm on
and now that I've I've learned better
how to communicate with this new medium
I'm able to reach a worldwide audience
and as one man I'm doing what I can to
make a difference in the lives of future
Generations
and so I'm seeing really really big
stuff ahead for the content that I'm
creating and for what I'm going to be
delivering to my viewers I always say
you know everything that I teach does
take a little bit of work and effort but
it's worth it because the fastest way to
get to the top
is to get off your bottom
man I love that kind of stuff like the
think media team knows that kind of
stuff like pumps me up and and one of
the things I love Matt is that you said
you're on a mission you know and I think
that's why we uh uh connect at such a
heart level because our mission at think
media is to help Purpose Driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love uh while making a difference
in the world with YouTube and online
video you're like what we consider uh
you know a perfect student just because
you're literally helping people learn
faster
um and and we hope to help people who
help people in fact we um talk about
this on our team meetings and we say we
don't want to measure success just
because like you joined our program
we're successful when your students are
successful that's how we define success
at think media we we're successful when
timi helps people get a passion for art
because we just start seeing the power
of legacy and impact it's like we we
think we want to help 10 000
purpose-driven people really make a
full-time living in a difference but
that's going to account for what people
say why not millions that is millions
that will be millions of people through
Matt through timi through you you know
that are here inside of the VRA group
and in the challenge group and I'm
curious uh this was actually your point
that I I brought on here you said it's
not too late Tammy you said you've got
this and so speak to that a little bit
of what you've experienced and just
recently starting your Channel
yes and first I just actually it's so
inspiring just listening to all of you
guys also and honestly two years ago I
would have thought oh yeah it's too late
but yet here I am 300 and something
thousand subscribers later it's amazing
how much growth you can get and I think
when you have tailored teaching like you
can get from VRA and think media it's
just amazing how far you can go but I'm
just here to tell you that I'm a
one-woman team I still make mistakes
everyone started somewhere if you look
at my first videos or when I came back
two years ago my videos were not doing
what I thought they were doing but yet
just continuous Improvement and just
like Matt was saying being a continued
being a continuous learner is just what
will get you to the top and it's not
easy if you compare your first video If
you compare your first few videos to my
videos to match videos it might not
match up but that's fine because that's
my 100 and something video and I think
it's just for you to actually face your
mission and just start now your voice
matters I'm just here to tell you that
you might not have the biggest channel
in the end but you're going to make an
impact to a lot of people and I think
that's what really matters the people
that just are waiting for your voice
it has some inspiring words there and uh
it is not too late to start listen uh we
want people to be able to follow you and
we've already shown your channel uh and
we'll have Matt on in just a second but
how can people connect with you shout it
out we've also got your Instagram go
ahead
oh sure yeah my channel is tebidanto Art
my Instagram Tammy underscore dancer
postmanally art videos I do have a
second channel that just started
um but yeah feel free to connect with me
I love it I love it and then Matt if
people want to connect from you with you
and learn faster uh as well as check out
any of your other resources shout it out
I'm at youtube.com forward slash be
smarter faster because I show you how to
be smarter faster you know School tells
you what to learn I teach you how to
learn it and in closing I'd like to wish
all of you the habits of the rabbits go
forth and multiply
Matt's got those phrases dialed daddy
you got all the you got the taglines and
the phrases I appreciate you so much
friends can we just show some love in
the comments for our guest today hearts
and likes on this stream definitely
check out their channels uh lifelong
leaders are lifelong Learners I love
being sharpened and inspired and
challenged from you from
the habits of the rabbits hey uh smash
like what a powerful conversation tell
me in the comments right now or in the
chat what was your favorite moment what
was an aha moment for you what did you
like best 10 tips and if you caught
those tips uh I know a few people are
typing the Recaps so drop me a recap of
those stick around because I actually
have some very recent information to
share with you though that I was
inspired from from this uh training but
share me some of your aha moments and
what did you like best
um I love Matt's phrases and uh I don't
know if this will all show up on screen
but there's there's a rough screenshot
Emoji wise of all of the tips thank you
so much for here's a cleaner one uh
start and be consistent you can
screenshot that right there there's your
10 tips all on screen but listen we
really need to talk about YouTube shorts
and then I have a limited time
announcement that I need you to know
about as well so hit the like button
drop your off aha moment and let's dive
into this really really quick you know
one of the things that uh it was
powerful that timi was talking about was
obviously what was happening with
YouTube shorts and you know we're in the
middle of this five day challenge and if
you haven't joined um yet I want to
encourage you there's a couple more days
to get into this challenge at uh tube1k
challenge.com and we might have a banner
for that and that link is in the
description if you happen to be watching
this stream uh publicly but uh one of
the things we need to know about YouTube
shorts is that YouTube's been making
some updated changes
um there's a new handles thing that's
rolling out which will allow you just
like we have Instagram handles YouTube
is allowing you to create a unique
handle for your channel specifically as
more of a short feature so that it's
easier to see not like a long channel
name but that's one thing that's
fascinating but the other thing that's
happening right now is I saw a question
about
Revenue split and timi was mentioning
that there's the shorts creators fund
well everything's changing going into
2023 YouTube is actually going to be
releasing a whole new wave of ads on
shorts which means we'll see a lot more
ads a lot of one a lot of them will be
playing in between so you'll be swiping
watching People's YouTube shorts then an
adult play
and in these clusters of people
consuming the shorts they're going to be
giving you as a Creator a 45 Revenue
split
so shorts a lot of people been getting a
lot of views but it's going to a whole
nother level what some people are saying
is YouTube's new ad program could steal
content creators away from Tick Tock so
we not just have been talking about all
this opportunity on YouTube
but one of the biggest opportunities is
YouTube continues to grow continues to
innovate and is continuing to find ways
to give you money and to ultimately be
the best paying platform in the Creator
economy there's no question about that
YouTube just added the voice over
feature so if you haven't taken the time
recently come on challenge come on think
media podcast come on Facebook if you
haven't grabbed your phone recently and
updated
your YouTube app when you go into your
YouTube app you can see all the creation
tools
number one number two have you
downloaded the YouTube studio app
did you know that there is a separate
app called the YouTube studio app which
is the back end with all kinds of data
and analytics yeah
and then you also might want to get that
YouTube kids app if you're a parent like
me and although Sean Bradley's been
seven days phone free Sony's on a whole
other level man she's like We're going
physical toys no screens and and we're
doing it she's amazing listen uh YouTube
shorts adds uh that and then recently
this is fascinating because you may have
wondered should I do shorts should I not
do shorts well Todd you can see on the
left side of the screen there that's
Todd Dupree he's the product manager
from YouTube and he was speaking at
VidCon and he was actually talking about
how shorts were basically a little wonky
when they first rolled out
if you posted shorts on your channel
they didn't quite talk to long form
content you know you might say I don't
like shorts it messes up the way my
channel looks that's all changing
one of the things he actually released
was he said listen to this he said
there's still more Lanes under
construction on the shorts to long form
Bridge don't judge the traffic flow
you're seeing today as the ultimate
potential of this path
Mr Beast was recently interviewed talked
about the same thing and they said do
you think Tick Tock is going to disrupt
YouTube he was like nah YouTube's gonna
crush this Whole Decade Man YouTube is
going to pay better Tick Tock probably
won't match that it's going to absorb
the creators the consumption the
attention will be there they're
committed to connecting the bridge as we
can see here the product manager is
connecting the bridge right of all of
that stuff and uh and so what does this
all add up to it just adds up to YouTube
being the absolute best platform to bet
on
uh they're going to organize and
separate your YouTube channel going into
2023 so if you're like I want my long
form videos to be pretty and be on like
the main page and I want my shorts to be
separate they're figuring out what would
be called the UI in the ux that's the
user interface and the user experience
that's going to be getting polished
they're paying creators and if you don't
want to do shorts you don't have to but
it's a good idea that you could do and
you could see that so much is coming to
YouTube in regards to the Future so much
so and here's a brand new quote and I
quote from the CMO of HubSpot he says
this this makes YouTube subscribers the
most valuable subscribers on the
internet
what does that mean better than
Tick-Tock followers better than
Instagram followers better than Facebook
likes YouTube subscribers are the most
valuable subscribers on the internet
YouTube is the best platform to be
betting on to be investing in and to be
thinking about so if you uh want to of
course learn more about this by the way
and you happen to be watching this we
stream this session on our podcast
Channel and if you haven't registered
there's still some time to register if
you've been a part of the challenge have
you been loving the tube 1K challenge
let me know and there's a couple more
live sessions and there is limited
replays available so I'm going to give
you a few practical things to do next if
you're serious about YouTube One
register for the challenge if you're not
registered for the challenge two don't
miss the morning session now I know we
have a global Community but on the 27th
of October
at 10 A.M in the morning we get there
early because we do giveaways we have a
whole nother session and that's going to
be amazing we'll be giving away just
really tactical information to get
access to all of that which is not going
to be streamed publicly like this stream
tube1kchallenge.com to definitely get
registered for that and uh I see your
comment I see you Cheryl this has been
some great info I love it Jonathan says
I've been loving it 100 yeah people uh
Raquel says the community and the live
information has been amazing yeah so
definitely lock into the challenge yes
we are starting at Pacific time I'm
coming to you from Las Vegas live at
this moment right here and so um
definitely join us for this 3 30 a.m
Aussie time respect for the hustle
additionally a couple other things to
know about is there is a limited time to
join our special offer on video ranking
Academy and I saw some questions coming
in about this actually
someone asked is there a link to VRA
I'll share that with you in just a
second uh David thanks for joining I see
uh pulling joining VRA tonight welcome
to the VRA fam excited to have you join
Shelton says I just purchased video rake
Academy today and I want all the extra
uh help Teresa says VRA is the way to go
um and so if you are interested in VRA
and I know some people were asking for
the link learn
video2023.com is the link to a very
special offer that we're doing and again
this isn't false hype you know we pride
ourselves on think media with
transparency Integrity when we do these
five-day challenges which there's only
two sessions left
three sessions left we're on session
four this is session four
we put together the best offer ever to
join VRA at the best price with the best
bonuses and what do I mean by that it's
not just our course called video ranking
Academy but we also have some special
bonuses and these are all at
learnvideo2023.com you can see them
pictured on screen
we include our Niche Finder video
creation Made Simple Workshop lifetime
membership and we are including our
full-time uh Creator course and so
there's three reasons why now would be
the time if you've been on the fence to
join video record Academy the first one
is literally the timing the opportunity
of YouTube right now Adobe just released
this you can see October 17th adobe's
future of create creativity study
revealed that over 50 of us creators are
now monetizing their content
the Creator economy is on fire and I
know there's a lot of disruption in a
lot of the different economy but right
now there is so much money flowing into
the crater economy and then what does
that mean it means content entrepreneurs
people creating content and building
businesses around it this is what the
data shows us it's three reasons to join
right now one is the timing this next
year this next decade is going to be the
best decade on YouTube influencer
marketing Hub said this and I quote I
love this quote the Creator economy is
the economy
and this is what they meant it's nearly
impossible for growing Brands to succeed
without Partnerships with influencers or
media channels
did you hear that the way that brands
are growing DC DTC Brands direct to
Consumer merch Brands coffee brands
drink Brands the way they're growing is
with influencers macro and micro
influencers the crater economy is the
marketing channel of today
so this offer if you've been on the
fence if you're not interested in doing
YouTube or you're not serious or you're
just dabbling then no this wouldn't be
for you but if you are serious
about planting your flag building your
brand starting or growing your YouTube
channel I want to invite you to be a
part of learn video 2023 because number
one now is the time to join number two
the second reason is this special offer
and if you join by Friday night we are
including an entire bonus course called
our full-time YouTube Creator course
everything you need to know about shorts
um what matters most for going on
YouTube today and specifically how to
create the shortest path to building a
full-time income this course alone has a
step-by-step workbook some bonus
downloads and it's in a thousand dollar
997 value on its own but it's no extra
charge this is an extra bonus just
rewarding you for jumping in before the
end of the challenge basically the
challenge ends on Friday
so between now and Friday whatever you
got to do you can check out all the
details at learnvideo2023.com
and then finally to see everything
you're going to get the the second
reason one is the opportunity going into
2023 2 is the offer this offer includes
video record Academy the private
Facebook group camera confidence Niche
Finder the private group q a sessions
the monthly private group q a sessions
our video creation Made Simple Workshop
lifetime access and if you join by the
end of the challenge the full-time
YouTube Creator course so the total
value of this is 11
752 dollars but we have a special offer
where you'll pay over 90 off at
learnvideo 2023 and so the final thing
is
the reason why three reasons why to join
now number one the time
all this opportunity shorts rolling out
monetizations rolling out too this
particular offer this does expire and if
you go to the website you'll notice
there's a countdown clock you can join
past Friday but I just have to be fully
transparent with you we're only going to
be giving that full-time Creator course
to people who join by Friday at the end
of the day which is the end of the
challenge just as a fast acting bonus to
honor you for being an action taker but
finally the third thing is the community
one of the powerful things about this
and for those that have been in the
challenge you might know you feel the
energy you feel the think media faculty
this is where we invest our energy at
think media at the highest level
not just our team though but the other
VRA members when you get around
possibility thinkers when you get around
people who see opportunity even in the
midst of adversity when you get around
people who are being creative when you
get around people like temmie and Matt
demaio like these are these are VRA
students in our private group you don't
just have the course you don't just have
the bonuses that you're getting you're
not just joining at the right time but
you're also around a community of
like-minded content entrepreneurs around
creative content creators business
owners and people that understand the
power of YouTube and want to be
connected to a community of
encouragement a community where there's
momentum building and then in a
community where this is what we geek out
about all the time like why wouldn't you
invest and be connected where we live
YouTube Breathe YouTube study YouTube
news release the facts to you stay on
the bleeding edge give you answers to
your questions this is just where we
live so again this wouldn't be right for
you if you were not serious about going
all in on YouTube but that's to me it's
that simple if you're serious about
going all in on YouTube
if you want to create extra income
streams Be Your Own Boss go part-time
quit your job go full time especially
with that full-time Creator course I
want to invite you to join us at
learnvideo
2023 that is where all the details are
that is your next step
um if you do have any questions
um thinkmediasupport.com there also is a
chat bubble if our team's not there you
can like leave a message or just go to
fakemediasupport.com we'd love to help
answer any questions that you have but I
want to thank you I appreciate you
Sharon we are here to support you uh
Jose thanks for being all in and being a
part of uh everything that we're doing
here Grace is all in really really
appreciates you
um and uh thank you for being a part of
this stream today that's right Raquel
surrounding yourself with like-minded
individuals is inspiring and uh we are
here for you and that is the community
that we are trying to create and so uh
my name is Sean Kendall Ryan its YouTube
channel thanks for being a part of
session four of the challenge smash like
wherever you're watching this subscribe
or follow if you're not subscribed and I
cannot wait to see you inside of session
number five of the tube 1K Challenge and
until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it